Are you in
Welcome back everyone this will be my new Flash
video for the end of the dceu James Gunn announced
his plans for the future of DC movies with a
reboot of the entire DC franchise and because
of that there are a bunch of changes happening to
the plot of The Flash movie along with Aquaman 2.
pretty much everything that's happening this
year and next year there are still four DC
movies coming out in 2023 that were part of the
old era of the DC EU and they're still releasing
them like they haven't changed that they haven't
canceled any of the movies that are coming out
next year so I'll explain what's changed all
the Cameo scenes that they've changed and all
the stuff that they were originally setting up
that has now changed because of all the DC plans
that James Gunn is making if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos it's still a developing situation so
I will continue to make videos for it as James
Gunn makes more announcements about the future DC
slate and movies he did say that they would make
more announcements at the beginning of next year
so we will find exactly what their plans are like
concrete plans for the next couple of years of
DC really soon I just did a video by about Henry
Cavill basically being fired as Superman good news
for him though like the day after that happened he
also released a trailer for The Warhammer Series
in an announcement about what his new plan is with
that going forward after he left the Witcher as
well I did a big trailer video for it so I'll link
it in the description below and at the end of this
it's a big W for Henry Cavill it's really good
news for him so I'm really happy that it worked
out because it really sucks that he's not going
to get to make Man of Steel too now because
as recently as October the entire plans for
the future of DC movies were completely different
like cut to November Everything Changes on a dime
what's happened since November is basically James
Gunn effectively ending what you knew as the dceu
story Universe of movies like The Zack Snyder
era of movies the snyderverse whatever you want
to call it funny thing about that though some of
his actors like The Suicide Squad movie actors in
The Peacemaker actors are taken from Zack Snyder
era movies like some of them are people that Zack
Snyder cast I will address that during the video
because if he is getting rid of everybody at DC
does that mean that he's also going to recast
all of his actors from The Suicide Squad movie
and what's going to happen with Peacemaker
season 2 in all the four DC movies that are
coming out next year were made as part of the
dceu under the old regime before James Gunn was
hired and made all those changes The Flash movie
in particular with all the craziness Ezra Miller
has been getting up to I think we all expected
them to recast him no matter what my name is Ezra
Miller and I am criminally excited to be a part
of the Justice League originally Warner Brothers
had a plan in place to use The Flash movie to set
up a new 10-year Justice League DC EU plan this
is like before October it would culminate in a
movie version of crisis on infinite earth like
DC's version of Avengers 5 King Dynasty Avengers 6
Secret Wars big Multiverse crossover movies split
into a couple parts they did a whole version of it
in the arrowverse a couple years ago I did videos
for all the episodes I'll link them Below in the
description it was great Tom Welling came back as
a version of Superman from Smallville Kevin Conroy
even got to play a live-action version of Batman
before he passed away may he rest in peace they
even had references to Michael Keaton's Batman
during that version of crisis on infinite Earths
they also established that the arrowverse was
Canon to the dceu through the Multiverse thus the
Ezra Miller Justice League Cameo scene it seemed
like they were going to use The Flash movie to set
up this new movie version of crisis on infinite
Earth that would tie everything together in even
bigger way but here's what's changed about all
the movies because of what James Gunn did back in
November like his new 10-year plan for DC and all
the recastings couple big changes made to some of
the movies that are coming next year reportedly
they've removed Henry cavill's Superman Cameo
scene in The Flash movie originally he had filmed
a Scene It was supposed to show up at the end of
the movie Inside the speed force to Barry Allen I
believe it was meant to be part of their larger
plans to bring Henry Cavill back as Superman
full-time for Man of Steel 2 in the Justice League
2 crisis on infinite Earth's plan that they were
trying to set up like it was meant to tease this
really big plot that was coming up now because
they're not doing that like they're not doing the
movie version of crisis on infinite Earth is going
to be James Gunn's plan with a completely
different version of future Justice League
different actors different everything and Henry
Cavill is not coming back as Superman I think the
idea is that they're just going to get rid of all
that stuff that was teasing future upcoming things
like we're not going to do that upcoming stuff so
there's no reason to tease it anymore he'd already
filmed the scene it's ready to go now it sounds
like we won't get to see it maybe fingers crossed
they'll release it as a deleted scene because that
would be great they've also reportedly cut gal
gadot's Wonder Woman Cameo scene in Shazam Fury
of the Gods she'd already filmed that too because
the Shazam movies are lighter in tone more comedic
her Cameo scene was part of a fantasy that Billy
Batson had that he was dating Wonder Woman Like
every teenage boy everyone in general just thirsty
for Wonder Woman during the movie that we're
going to show you part of that fantasy and then
he actually winds up seeing Wonder Woman in person
and they just pay off the joke about his fantasy
in a funny way The Rock was also supposed to have
a Black Adam Cameo seen in the movie like Shazam
versus Black Adam kind of Cameo scene reportedly
he turned down the opportunity when given to him
a while ago and because all these changes were
made James comes hired all the dceu plans are
changing everyone's being recast supposedly now
the Rock is in the middle of feuding with Warner
Brothers over his future at the studio like he was
trying to set up his own self-contained franchise
surrounding the Black Adam character the rumor
now is that he's done as Black Adam like no Black
Adam sequels no Superman vs Black Adam and the
other Heartbreaker no Shazam versus Black Adam
which they've been teasing for years ever since
the ending of that first movie who's that for
well whoever it is I'm gonna love them no matter
what because they're an automatic part of the
family I did videos about this like a couple
years ago when the movie first came out but if you
didn't realize that missing person that they were
referring to was meant to be Black Adam originally
he was written to be in the movie but the rock
wanted to separate him to develop this other
franchise for Black Adam specifically talking
more about the future of Batman because Batman
is a big character during The Flash movie a couple
different versions of Batman both Ben Affleck and
Michael Keaton's Batman were supposed to be in
The Flash movie Ezra Miller's flash was supposed
to get the flash ring and his brand new costume
from Ben Affleck's Batman like the actual flash
ring is given to him by Ben Affleck's Batman they
did it in Italian comic recently I don't know that
they've taken any of Ben Affleck's scenes out of
the movie it sounds like he was a bigger part of
the movie so it'd be a little bit harder to just
completely cut his scenes out even before James
Gunn came on Ben Affleck was trying to transition
away from being Batman like this was meant to be
his big swan song he filmed the Cameo scene for
Aquaman 2. is meant to be like his last big hurray
as the character and before James Gunn came on
and changed all these plans originally their
grand plan for the future of the Justice League
movies crossover Batman was that during The Flash
movie they would set up Michael Keaton's Batman
as the new crossover Justice League Batman you
may have seen the post recently where James Gunn
jumped on the reporter who was trying to say that
Robert Pattinson's Batman was going to be the new
crossover Batman James Gunn was going to change
everything and Matt Reed's Universe was going to
connect with the Justice League movies but then
James Gunn was like hell no we're not doing that
and Matt Ruiz was like oh thank you for not making
me cross over with the Justice League movies then
you probably saw that they canceled the Batgirl
movie Michael Keaton had a cameo role during that
they call it a glorified Cameo he wasn't like a
huge part of the movie but that was also part of
their earlier plans to make him this big crossover
Batman because James Gunn said that part of the
reason for recasting Henry cavill's Superman with
a younger actor was because they wanted to do a
story earlier in Superman's life like they were
going to do what they did for Robert Pattinson's
Batman into Superman year two not an origin story
for superman but a story earlier in his life he
said that Robert Pattinson's Batman would not
cross over with the future DC movies but Batman
would be a big part of the future interconnected
DC movies this implies that they're actually
changing their plans in Michael Keaton's Batman
will not be their crossover Batman anymore and
they're going to recast another version of Batman
who will do all the Crossovers so we'll still have
two live-action version of Batman supposedly after
all the recastings everything next year we don't
know who that second version of Batman is and he
hasn't said anything about who's going to cast
for this new version of Superman DC basically
canceled Wonder Woman 3. it also sounds like they
might might wind up recasting Gal Gadot but she
could stay on just because so many of the actors
are being recast doesn't mean that every single
one will but it implies that they might like I'm
not going to hold my breath that Gal Gadot stays
as Wonder Woman also during The Flash trailer you
probably saw that they were going to introduce a
Multiverse version of Supergirl on Michael Keaton
Batman's Earth 89 whatever you want to call it her
logo is the same as Henry cavill's Superman logo
so that even though she comes from the Multiverse
the version of Krypton she comes from seems like
it's very similar if not the exact same as the
version that Henry Cavill came from they were
developing a solo movie for her that they were
going to do on HBO Max but as part of separate
plans they basically got rid of the whole idea
the whole concept of doing movies exclusively for
HBO Max that wasn't part of James Gunn's play that
was like a whole separate thing Super Girls movie
got canceled the same way that Batgirls movie got
canceled it's just they hadn't started filming
the Supergirl movie yet and even though the
Flash movie is doing a version of Flashpoint it's
meant to be like a slightly different version it
sounds like what they'll do now is they'll try
to treat it like a one-off movie in a different
Universe in James Gunn's new DC Universe going
forward will be set in Another Universe like just
completely fresh completely different continuity
so basically what they're doing with all the DC
movies next year including The Flash movie even
though it was meant to set up a whole bunch of
stuff is try to re-edit the movies or remove
scenes that were teasing future things that
will never be paid off now so that each of the
movies feels as self-contained as possible like
less crossover than there was before and just
treat it like a one-off adventure with those
particular characters and then he'll reboot
everything after those movies they might retune
the ending of The Flash movie so that there's a
version of Flashpoint that helps explain the big
reboot that's coming let's just blame everything
on the flash and when he changes everything and
everybody shows up looking different acting
different and they don't remember what happened
before that's why like oh well the flash messed
it up when it comes to some of James Gunn's core
actors like The Suicide Squad actors like Margot
Robbie's Harley Quinn Peacemaker season 2 John
Cena's character this is where we get to the
idea that I think that he's just rebooting a
lot of the major stuff and some of the minor stuff
will continue and they'll just Loosely address it
like a couple of the actors will be the same but
largely it will look very different maybe some of
the characters and some of the future projects
will have some jokes about that too like why do
you look so different from the other version of
Superman that I met a little while ago once they
start promoting some of these movies they start
dropping some trailers I'm sure there's going
to be a thousand questions but don't be surprised
if some of the subsequent and trailers look very
different from the early trailers and teasers they
released last year for some of these movies like
wait a minute where'd all the characters go like
it was completely different before is all because
of this upcoming reboot everyone click here for
that new Henry Cavill Warhammer trailer Big W for
him really happy for him and click here for my
avatar the way of water ending and easter eggs
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!